my mother my holy death
I like the humblest of your children you
I ask
the now and the indicated moment
without fear and with faith that already accepts all
world and that the one who wants to be with her
forward and the one who does not also
Beforehand she will come for all
we beg you, madam madam
let's see
ah
and here
I came here to the USA because like any
immigrant anyone who wants
get ahead this if it comes from comes from
child at the passage of 7 years later was that
started the change and this in advance
We know that Mexico is a country
totally macho more than anything else
in the families their traditional I
I decided to come out of my house and I
I came to this country without telling anyone
without notifying my family the saint
death has always existed
comes from our ancestors then be
this case they adored then a
ancestral culture
Hello
all right
we know it's a lady who has the
largest temple in the world in which
this one are now given prayers are
explains what is the holy death is
they make baptisms they are married
confirmations of everything
to the pious to the incongruous
and especially to us your children
present he believed a lot in the saint
death and I do not
I do not respect your belief
now
and I want to make me forgive for him too
here I found a formed
to continue living
for me the holy death is an angel the
Angel of Death
someone who will one day come by
we many want to join their lives
with the blessing of my holy death
They decide to join their lives here before our
holy death remember that what my
santa still
nobody can separate them or after the
death
I am undocumented when I came in
arizona desert we passed at night and
we have to go through where there are some
burladeros at night you could not see anything of
night I fell and I hurt myself in the two
knees could not walk and like them
they went ahead they left me lost then
I started to pray pray to pray pray that
will help me out and helped me out
by my own means I went out the next day
to the highway and I managed to achieve
get through until promised
getting a tattoo is what one of the
promises that I made to him and I did it
her godmother adelina lights up in this
moment that light that will illuminate their lives
good
so
spinach
the
and so I have
I name you
at this moment godmother of our cult
of our cult to holy death to
from this moment
you are going to represent our most holy
death here in new york '
and he does not have it
s
then hortalà change is now ready
for
for the mornings in the morning
a very special moment that moment
it's only mine
and these are the mañanitas that sings
the border
it was lovely
do not
I sing
m
I'll see
it's something more
do not
sometimes a lot of people maybe see the shows
of transsexuals think álava because
maybe we are ridiculous are clowns
no but there are about 60 20 enjoyed it and more
that you are feeling compost as a
artist not
in this cult there is no military there is no
policemen there are no criminals there are only
brothers
to my holy death today declined my position
towards you to achieve the sanity that
you deposit in me
bringing my mother to you the most
great of my being
my love for my life my life my death
keep my all my side
of everything you want
health money
and prosperity
my mother my holy death I like the most
humble of your children I ask you my mother
I beg you I implore you I beg of you
let's get to you